how can you design here in Asia a more
modern Park which is more environmental
friendly more sustainable which gives
space for different generations places
where people can enjoy in the morning
doing Tai Chi having Gardens where they
can do their own gardening kids to play
people to experience the environment the
strategic plan for the park is really to
bring the blue and the green together
and on top of that get the life the
people you know to make it a vibrant
place where the park can be used as open
as multi functional as possible but also
to do something for the water to slow
down the water to keep it clean to
actually be more environmental
orientated with the water and on top of
that to bring the wildlife back into the
city we also designed everything in this
park we designed the bridges we designed
the seedings we designed the light
pillars we designed the shade structures
we made decks where you can actually
look over we made stepping stones to
cross through the water and all what you
can see even here the stabilization of
river besides or the plants or the
islands are all highly engineered they
all worked out with different techniques
how to stabilize it and they all have
under constructions so when there's a
lot of water and the water can you
really come out very high there is no
erosion we want to keep them here we
want to have that that place look good
and really to stabilize also everything
we did also the site supervision and we
did the quality control which i think is
very important and that basically brings
me to this point what is really the
precision of a good designer and of good
design it's not done that you just make
a nice drawing or have a good concept I
think you have to really follow through
the entire process to the site
supervision to the construction firms
and to double check that everything is
done well how people are touched
inwardly you know how beautiful it is if
you are in a park and you see your child
looking in water playing and discovering
this beautiful life of a little
dragonfly or to see how beautiful it is
you know to have the flowering here the
water here and to see this connection of
life and water and to understand that
you know this is something of a very
very sort of deep-rooted inside of life
process and I think that's very
important
you